so let's start shall we it's taking us
this long we're finally going to begin
motion you can draw one of these by the
way and we're going to fill it in
motion motion motion uh actually the the
topic
is not really called motion it is called
displacement
velocity and acceleration but that's a
bit of a mouthful
um and it really is just talking about
things that move right
hence motion bless you so a lot of
people don't like this topic because
um they're like i didn't choose physics
as a subject
like i didn't choose it for the specific
reason to avoid all of this rubbish okay
and now you're telling me i have to do
it and even if you drop down a two unit
instead of three in it
you still have to do it um the only way
you can get out of
motion is to do general mats actually um
which you cannot do at this school you
have to do it
yeah no sorry you can do it but distance
um but then you have to deal with like
annuities and
actually the season sequences believe it
or not the season sequences in general
is a lot worse than it is in um
in two unit three anyway i digress
we have to do motion okay um and i want
to try and get
across the fact that physics and maths
right that's what my two circles are
um physics and maths
you can't avoid the fact that they're
intertwined okay
but to help you wrap your mind around
how what we're doing
is not physics it's emphatically
non-physics let me try and explain what
the difference is okay
um physics is a science okay and
strictly speaking
maths is not okay maths is closer to
philosophy
than it is to science the reason why is
because how do you know something
scientifically like what is the
scientific method
it's about experiment right it's about
experiment and observation
okay so everything in science is about
can you
look at something can you repeat it um
and we're thinking about like things in
the actual world which we can look at
okay um now instead of experimentation
right when you're thinking about maths
how does maths work
well rather than i said it was like
philosophy right you're just trying to
think up how something works or how it
fits together or if there's a pat
you're almost trying to make it up right
as opposed to i'm watching something do
something right and i'm watching i'm
trying to get its pattern from watching
it
as opposed to maths is all up here right
it's all
all the things that we do in maths are
all fabricated they're not real there's
like
there's a man and he's investing money
and there's no real man that you're
watching and observing
you're making it up right so instead of
experimentation
i would call this imagination right
everything is
none of it's real okay none of it is
whoa
anyway that's right the cake is a lie
okay so experimentation
observation versus imagination in the
same way
right what you're thinking about in
terms of physics is natural phenomena
um if it can't happen in the real world
physics is not interested in it
right some things that we uh
don't think could exist do exist and
because they're in the real world like
say black holes
right you can't see a black hole but you
can see its effect it is a natural
phenomenon so that's why physics is
interested in it
okay where's matt what does it deal with
it's not looking at
things in the real world and trying to
look at their patterns it's about
imagining things
particularly about logical connections
um and relationships
okay how does one thing fit to another
rather than getting there by observation
you're getting there just just by logic
now as you can see there is an overlap
right
physics and maths do uh sit on top of
one another and you can't do one
without the other and it's it's rather
silly to think of one without thinking
about how it relates to the other
so motion fits right in between here
right
motion is is the overlap between them
but can you see
the physicists and mathematicians think
about they approach motion in two very
different ways
okay so we're going to approach it from
the angle of
equations and calculus right
okay well if you got an equation like
this and your difference here you
integrate what happens what does that
mean
okay whereas in terms of motion we're
thinking observations we're like well
this thing
this uh you know the light from this
star seems to get brighter every now and
then like why is that
right so it has to do with the motion of
say a planet in front of it which is
lensing the light and so on
right so coming from different
directions okay but by the way
this is not the first time you've
actually looked at things which
relate to physics right um you know
earlier this year
we're looking at rates of change you
know balloons that got bigger or things
that change in temperature that's
physics
right except obviously we start with an
equation and our imagination
something which you know it exhibits
these characteristics that we just make
up
versus well here's a thing let's measure
it okay get a thermometer and stick it
in
okay um and later this year we're going
to get onto one more
i mean this is not exhaustive of this
but you've probably thought about this
already
the topic that's called exponential
growth and decay right
which is about populations but it's also
about like radioactive stuff that
um whittles away because it's half-life
and all that kind of thing
we usually think of that as a domain of
the physicists right which it is but
it's also
something you can just be thought of
purely mathematically
okay so if you want to put it one more
way this is this is
all practical this is theoretical the
words we use
or the ones that universities would use
is that this is um
applied they would actually call physics
applied maths
or they would call this pure maths
okay so
that gives you an idea of how these two
relate to each other okay does that make
sense
so i hope um that kind of wraps your
brain around
how these two relate and relax we're not
going to be doing all the physique stuff
for instance by the way ironically you
know
and this is what i mean by physics can't
work without mass right
um you have all of these equations
hands-on who does physics how many of
you do physics
okay right so you you guys thank you
hands down you'll have learned all these
equations about forces
um and mass and velocity all that kind
of thing right like
um ut plus a t squared and all that um
we don't use any of them when we're
thinking about motion from a
mathematical perspective
okay so in fact they're not valid to use
you can't like quota and say well this
is self-evidently true even though
it sort of is uh it's true because of
observation
right and so since it's coming from that
side that's why we don't deal with it
from a mathematical angle okay so just
to pre-op because whenever i teach
motion
people always ask me the physics
students they're like this would be so
much faster
if i could just use the result then i
already know it don't have to
differentiate improve from scratch
well the point is we're trying to
approach this one idea from another
angle from the mathematical angle
okay so that's why we don't use physics
equations